un amas de sable et d'algues sargas
voilà la cause des tourments de Manuel
marin pêcheurs du Vauquelin aujourd'hui
comme depuis deux semaines il regarde la
mer et son embarcation impuissant devant
ce mélange qui finit par en baser le
port de pêche en fait on a un souci qui
s'est ajouté un autre souci ce qu'on
avait dit à le problème de d'un vasement
du port de pêche qui nous gênait
beaucoup et aujourd'hui on a encore
l'ajout de Sargasses en décomposition
qui s'est rajouté à la vase donc
aujourd'hui on peut plus aller pêcher
une couche de vase de plus de 3 m
d'épaisseur c'est l'estimation des
pêcheurs et c'est une quarantaine de
professionnels de la mère de cette
commune qui patient de la situation
Nolan lui a réfléchir mais il organise
également des balades en mer et sa
sortie du jour est compromise
c'est pas possible depuis plusieurs
années maintenant le phénomène est
récurrent pourtant de mémoire d'aimer on
n'avait jamais vu cela
va sortir
la municipalité affirme prendre des
dispositions pour les accompagner 40000
euros nous dit-on 20 000 en janvier
autant en février déjà dépensé pour le
ramassage des algues brunes mais il
faudrait aller plus loin hier j'ai
décidé mails j'ai appelé la CTM pour
trouver une solution plus pérenne et
plus massive parce que je pense qu'il
faut faire intervenir une drague pour
pouvoir aspirer toute cette vase qui
justement colmat le port les pêcheurs
vous clinois disent vouloir simplement
aller travailler dans l'attente d'une
intervention ils sont contraints de
patienter car même le système D ne peut
venir à bout de ce qui à marée basse
devient une plage